à quel point le panneau solaire à cent pour cent
salue-t-il la fin, il aurait pu être nettoyé par le
vent, regardez Rover -
selon les journaux, le commandant Lewis l'
a sorti Sol 17 l'a branché sur l'
habit pour le recharger, il a été déplacé pourquoi
ne pas simplement  demandez à Lewis, allons sur
Capcom et demandez-lui directement non
non si Watney est vraiment vivant, nous ne
voulons pas que l'équipage d'Ares 3 sache comment pourriez-
vous ne pas leur dire qu'ils ont encore 10
mois pour leur voyage de retour, je suis désolé mais
vous n'avez pas réfléchi à cela, je veux dire
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire qu'il est à 50
millions de kilomètres de chez lui, il pense
qu'il est totalement seul depuis que nous l'avons
abandonné et qu'est-ce que cela fait à un homme
psychologiquement l'enfer pense-t-il en
ce moment je '  Je vais certainement mourir
là-haut si je dois écouter encore plus de
musique disco horrible, mon dieu le commandant
Lewis ne pourrais-tu pas emporter quoi que ce soit de
ce siècle